here with more co-host fox and friends
weekend pete heggseth along with former
acting director of national intelligence
rick grinnell pete i know
you pulled out your phone with passion
the other night on this program you and
like so many others i know rick i know
you've been involved in this as well
talking to people that you know friends
of yours that are stuck that are on the
ground or they're the people that allied
with us we promised them pete if this
day ever came we'd get them the hell out
there's no way we can get him out now is
there
not even close sean the only plan that's
in play is the taliban plan we've been
playing by their playbook and we've been
hoping by it and today
it manifests in the worst possible way
god bless the souls of these 13 marines
of these men
and their families and all they've given
and they were failed by the byte
administration who did not adjust their
strategy so we knew there was a threat
from isis k and i've been a platoon
leader i've been on a wall guarding a
defense if you know there's a threat and
we knew it for 24 hours you either you
have to change your strategy you either
get more defensive or you go proactive
and defend that perimeter they did
neither knowing the threat was there
because they've been relying on our
enemy on the taliban to deliver for them
and to taliban delivered exactly exactly
what we should expect from them death
and violence nothing will get better
from here and joe biden said nothing it
would i everyone i know was watching
what was said today and everyone i know
was disappointed by the fact that our
commander-in-chief cannot deliver a let
alone a coherent sentence a coherent
idea other than we rely on the taliban
which is relying on the people who want
to kill us and the people who will be
left behind are the first people on
their list to kill and it is a disgrace
for our country you know rick i keep
going back because the the taliban was
on the march we we watched them in april
and may and june it should have been uh
you know a five-alarm fire
while we had control of kabul all of
this could have been done with no risk
to anybody's life all of our allies
could have been extracted every american
could have been brought home all of our
equipment could have been brought home
or at the very least destroyed none of
that happened now from my understanding
is and based on your background this was
not an intelligence failure that the
intel community had it right they
themselves pulled their own people out
and they were sounding the call daily is
that what you're hearing
this was not an intelligence failure
this was a failure of politicians in
washington dc you're exactly right they
started briefing intelligence community
state department officials a whole bunch
of people started briefing in may
telling them that the taliban was on the
march remember that donald trump
handed joe biden a stable afghanistan
and a functioning
embassy and and
in that functioning embassy there were
foreign service officers i think that
what's going to happen sean
is the strategic blunder is going to be
closing bagram air base why was bagram
closed and the secretary of state
anthony blinken and the deputy secretary
of state wendy sherman why were they not
screaming to say you cannot close bagram
and remove u.s troops when we have an
embassy
in harm's way in a
war zone and yet that's exactly what
happened our secretary of state allowed
state department employees
to be in harm's way without the military
i think that it's not too much and i say
this very calmly it's not too much to
say that anthony blinken should resign
wendy sherman should resign both in
disgrace for leaving state department
employees
in a war zone and sitting in a cabinet
meeting and allowing bagram to be closed
look we had we just saw the president of
the united states knock on wood
that was his plan
i can tell you donald trump would not be
knocking on wood right now
he would have had a plan and something
else would have been knocking
it wouldn't have it wouldn't have gotten
to this point we all know that i know
you both have been working very hard to
help people you know to get out and
working every channel you have i applaud
your hard work and efforts thank you
both hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else